[Music]
the essential ph-1
essential
ph one essential for
see what you i see what you did there
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the essential phone it's a new phone
from a new company but with a not so new
philosophy of just sticking with the
essentials you know no bells and
whistles no fancy widgets or crazy
features or head turning stuff
just
700
of the pure essentials i'll be using
this phone for a little bit now and i
have a pretty good idea of how well they
did and whether you should buy one or
not so that's what this video is so
first of all the hardware is awesome and
that's usually really hard for new
companies to get right off the bat so
i'm impressed here the essential phone
feels great in the hand it's this all
black titanium and ceramic slab no
protrusions at all
no logos at all no branding or anything
like that it's just an essential
rectangle with rounded corners the
titanium sides that material is actually
a lot harder than your typical aluminum
so that means you should hold up to
chipping or any drops much better and
the back which you could easily mistake
for gorilla glass is not glass at all it
is polished ceramic so that makes it
much harder than glass making it way
less likely to scratch it all but also
theoretically making it more likely to
break since ceramic is more brittle than
gorilla glass basically what i'm saying
is this would be a really interesting
phone to drop test
but no i won't i'll leave that to other
channels but what you will notice right
out the box though is the ceramic makes
the phone a bit heavier just more dense
feeling in the hand and it's also a
serious fingerprint magnet it's like a
mirror finish which is super nice when
it's clean but it will never be clean so
definitely worth getting a dbrand skin
on the back of this one and it can
actually make the phone look a lot
better than without the skin if you ask
me this is one of those rare instances
so i'll link to this matte black one
right below that like button but long
story short i like the industrial design
here it's simple not too flashy but
obviously still has a signature look
only thing you're missing here is
waterproofing a lot of other phones in
this price range have some ip
certification not this one maybe next
year the fingerprint reader on this guy
is actually pretty quick to recognize
your finger but it always feels like
there's a tiny delay when i actually
turn the screen on and unlock the phone
if you can see that
it's not bad but you can definitely
address that with a software update and
the rest of the back of the phone is the
mic and two pins for attaching small
modular accessories and providing power
through them so the one that exists
right now is the world's smallest 360
degree camera it just snaps right into
place with magnets in the phone which is
really convenient so hopefully there are
more mods added to their ecosystem
sooner than later i don't have any of
them right now but we'll have to wait
and see how good that gets the speaker
for those who care is it's actually
really loud it gets very very loud but
it's not like the best quality loud so
there's no big dynamic range there's no
bass or anything like that it's just
really loud and it's also this small
pretty blockable grille at the bottom of
the phone and
there's also no headphone jack anywhere
on the essential phone
so
audio is clearly not a priority with
this guy so yeah i guess the easiest
joke to make about the essential phone
is they didn't include a headphone jack
which is essential to most people
seems kind of weird yes i do think they
could have included one
but they didn't welcome to 2017 i guess
anyway around the front is the 5.7 inch
display with a sort of the signature
look at this point the cutout in the top
of the middle for the front-facing
camera and the absolutely tiny bezels on
the top and the sides originally i
thought i wouldn't like this or it might
get distracting or annoying but i can
tell you right now that disappears just
a couple hours into using it and the
phone looks awesome in my opinion with
the thin bezels we just talked about
this in the most recent video yes
technically moving the display way up
closer to the corners would seem to make
it easier to damage it with a drop but
the ceramic and titanium should also
work against that and all the times that
the phone isn't using the full display
it just blocks out that bar to match the
bottom bezel so it looks like a
completely normal phone most of the time
anyway it's also a quad hd display and
it gets up to 500 nits so decently
bright but not the brightest like i can
see outdoors but i've seen better in
fact the only real downside i can see
with this screen is that it's not an
oled if it were an oled you could do
some cool tricks with totally blacking
out the top and the bottom or you could
do some cool wallpaper tricks where it
fades to complete blackness up at the
top and you could do some cool essential
tricks where you like only light up a
display for notifications instead of the
whole thing little things like that but
it's not it's an lcd which you know
that's just fine for now maybe next year
but where this phone really lives up to
the name the essential
is in the software it is
so clean this phone is rocking basically
stock android 7.1.1 and i imagine it'll
be getting android 8.0 oreo through a
software update pretty soon it's already
gotten two software updates since i got
the thing and so once you get past the
essential boot screen you get you know
stock google launcher stock android
notification shade just a couple google
apps installed absolutely zero bloatware
out the box the only third party app
installed on this phone when you get it
is the camera app which we'll get to in
a second so this is delivering
essentially the exact same software
experience as a pixel no extra features
are buried in the settings no waving
gestures or iris scanning no extra
assistance or any of that the essential
part in the settings is just to tick
whether or not you want to send
diagnostic data to the company or not
it's just just android it's clean the
pure base essentials and so of course
because of that performance is great i
mean it's also because of the specs too
you know snapdragon 835 4 gigs of ram
you don't need the craziest specs to run
pure android smoothly but this phone
balls out gaming is fine multitasking is
fine hiccups aren't at zero but they're
minimal and lag doesn't happen much at
all
except in the camera in fact you know
what let's let's talk about the camera
this is the weakest part of the device
straight up so if you were looking for a
reason not to buy this phone if you want
to tell someone why not to buy it link
them to this part of the video the
essential phone actually has two cameras
on the back a 13 megapixel color camera
and a 13 megapixel monochrome camera and
they're used together to enhance the
detail and contrast and sharpness in
everyday regular photos unfortunately
most people will never actually notice
this so the only other benefit just ends
up being it can also take black and
white photos in the camera app and the
camera app is the only app that i've
ever really seen lag hard on this phone
and it's been pretty consistently slow
it lags to take photos it lags when
turning hdr on and off and it lags big
time when switching between modes if you
have a lot of stuff going on so that's
really disappointing and it's not even
like it's a super complex camera app in
fact it's one of the simplest camera
apps possible every option available to
change is shown on the screen right now
so there's no other hidden settings
there's no manual mode no pro mode this
is it and then the photos themselves are
pretty mediocre at best again you would
think a phone at this price that adds a
second sensor just to add detail and
dynamic range would be great with the
sharpness and photos something seems
like it really focuses on photography
but the photos from this phone are still
soft they're lacking dynamic range
they're noisy in anything but perfect
lighting and often have the totally
wrong exposure altogether
turning hdr on also didn't help as much
as i thought it would you've seen hdr
from other phones like the s8 and the
pixel they're great but this one barely
adds a little bit back to the highlights
and that's it so the lacking camera and
camera app here are pretty disappointing
even the videos off it are really shaky
and also disappointing the one thing
about photos and videos though is they
can be improved via software updates in
fact that's usually the number one thing
that gets the most improved over time
with smartphones software updates
but i've still never seen one go from
not good to really good with just
software updates so i feel pretty safe
saying you're not going to want to buy
this phone for the camera what you
should buy this phone for are the great
stock software experience that's pretty
obvious it's clean and pretty unique you
could buy it for the premium build
quality the ceramic and titanium as far
as i can see aren't combined like this
in any other smartphone you might even
get it for the battery life this thing
gets great battery life it's been really
impressive for a 3040 milliamp hour
battery
and a 5.7 inch display but i keep
getting four to four and a half hours of
screen on time so it lasts comfortably
all day you might even get it for just
the little things you like about it the
display the tiny notification led right
above the screen which gets really
bright or bluetooth 5.0 or even the
awesome accessories included in the box
which are also first of all totally
non-branded no logo anywhere but also
really high quality and really cool to
see a smartphone bundle braided high
quality cables in the box that feel like
they're going to last a long time and a
super high powered 27 watt charger that
goes extremely fast so the bottom line
is would i would i recommend buying this
phone
and as much as i enjoyed using it
probably not don't get me wrong it's
awesome to see a new company get so much
right in their first try but at the same
time it is 700 bucks so it's kind of for
me like it's floating around in that
void of
other really good smartphones from the
established manufacturers for the same
price you could get a galaxy s8 that
also has a software skin but also has a
way better camera and also has
waterproofing and a headphone jack or
for the same price you could also get a
google pixel from last year which may
have bigger bezels but it has better
speakers and it gets the exact same
software updates but way faster we can
just wait for the new pixel to come out
this year that'll have smaller bezels
and the new software so essential phone
to me is a great episode one it's a
great start and i'm excited for episode
two when essential phone two comes out
hopefully has one or two more
distinguishing features at that price
range that aren't proprietary mods and
then i'll be really into it and i'll
probably be more likely to recommend it
but until then this is still really cool
to see save your money thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]